now
uh today is lecture two and we're going
to be
talking about counting and we're going
to be talking about the mole
which is a way to count to help us count
and then and this is really exciting
we're going to be building this
and that is super exciting now everybody
should have gotten one of these
on the first day we'll be talking about
this later in the lecture
if you don't have this and for that
matter if you oh there's laura
laura has like thousands of these and if
you need one
um uh please ask laura enough also if
you need a goodie bag
which we gave out on the first day uh
please get in touch with laura and
she'll give you one
we have extras here you can stop by our
office later get one
please today all right now
last uh uh lecture we left off with
uh remember those guys like boyle and
priestly
and uh and lavoisier conservation of
mass
right and what these guys were doing
is they were they were smashing and and
burning and
pushing on things and trying to figure
out
what it was that was that that that
sort of fundamental object that you
couldn't break apart anymore
and remember it was democritus that said
there is such a thing right
he said there was this such a thing
called adams atomos
and so we come to dalton who said look
these things were trying we're calling
them elements right now
let's in honor of that indivisibility
idea
let's call them atoms and
and dalton did a lot of really important
experiments and he was also
trying to smash and break and measure
and figure out
what what are these indivisible in in
what are these things that you can't
break apart anymore what are these atoms
how many of them are there what do they
do
and uh he came up with a pretty
important uh uh observation which is a
he called it the law of multiple
proportions
and um and in this so so what dalton did
is he said look i'm going to take
something and react it with something
else
and it's going to react fully okay so
so there's no limiting reagent there's
no excess it's just everything reacted
here and everything
i'm going to measure how much stuff
reacts and then how much i get
and and so if you take like an example
of this law of multiple proportions
if you take an example of how that came
about what he observed is that if you
had sort of
for example um maybe you had sort of
case
one and you
you you react some amount so he's going
to react some amount
so let's say he reacted okay
i don't know some amount let's write it
yeah some amount of something
maybe carbon and some amount of
something else
how about oxygen and he would get
some amount right okay you know he's
doing all these calculations he's doing
all his measurements so i'm trying to
get you back in that mood
how much do i have i don't know weigh it
measure it that's what he was doing over
and over
but he had some amount of something
aha now he would do this over and over
again
some amount of car okay i'm just taking
these two elements as an example he did
this for many many elements
right so so some amount of carbon with
some and
in case one you find okay everything
reacts
and i get this carbon to oxygen
mass ratio
of let's say 1 to 1.33
i measure it
that that's how much of the sum amount
right
1 to one point three three reacts
fully remember no excess
because it adds a little more and it's
excess no this
reacts fully then you do it again
case two and he'd find that this same
ratio
was 1 to 2.66
and he noticed a pattern and he noticed
a pattern
and he called it the law of multiple
proportions because what he found is
that
you could keep on going and in some
cases not all cases
but in some cases like carbon and oxygen
for example
these these would come in ratios these
series
right 3 2.66 divided by 1.33
is an integer these things would happen
in in integer ratios
integer amounts so i could i could keep
going and maybe i'd get three or four
right and and what that means is that
well over here this some amount of
something is it says something about the
something
right because it says maybe this maybe
these somethings
are some are like co and
co2 right for example
maybe oh but not definitely
and that frustrated dalton that
frustrated him
we'll come back to that in a sec right
but he did this and he and he and he saw
he observed these
these these ratios these integer ratios
of
what would react with what he's trying
to figure out what's
what is he making right what is he
making
now um now he
he also as with lavoisier remember i
showed you the lavoisiers tableau
well he had his own table
and and here it is so here's in 1827
he had identified 36 elements
now the thing is though um okay point
one if you're going to try to brand
something
which he clearly tried with these
symbols you can't make him this
complicated
right i'm pretty happy that that's not
how we write our elements
you can see that this would be very hard
but he did come up with these symbols
and
and
you can see it'd be very hard to keep
going uh without getting complicated so
i think we're pretty lucky that
brazilians
came along and figured out how to name
these elements in a consistent way
but that wasn't his real problem his
real problem was what i just alluded to
see he he knew that he had these
different elements
but he didn't know what the compositions
were he had he was so close
he was so close he could see that these
ah but
is it co and co2 or is it co2 and co4
that he didn't know that he didn't know
because he didn't have
an accurate way to measure the mass of
an atom not at that time
right but he did have this this this
nice ability to see these series
okay but in comes other
measurements and you had guy lusak who
was looking at volumes right
and and so guy luck was saying oh look
if i take
a certain amount of volume of a gas
right one gas
and i and i react it again completely no
excess okay and i react it with another
gas
and then i see i get something else over
here right i can measure the volumes and
i do this for the cases where
there's nothing left over nothing
limited it
and so he would find for example what's
shown up there
you know he would find that
you've got for every two volumes of
hydrogen gas
so he's got two volumes of hydrogen that
he would react with one volume
of oxygen and he would notice
that he would get two volumes of
something
that had let's not put a dash there it
had hydrogen
and oxygen in it he knew that now he
knew this because he was very careful
right so nothing leaked he said no
everything is accounted for
lavoisier holds right conservation of
mass
i'm not losing anything here and as
lavoisier said in a chemical reaction
mathis
mass is neither created nor destroyed
so i know that whatever is over here
must consist of whatever i had here
oxygen and hydrogen
and he kept doing it for other you know
lots of different types of gases
but it was very strange because what
happened is sometimes
you know sometimes you'd get
the volumes are the same so you'd get
like he did it for hydrogen and chlorine
one volume of hydrogen and one volume
of chlorine would give you two volumes
of hydrogen and chlorine something that
had hydrogen and chlorine in it
and so there you'd mix one and add
another one
and you'd get two it seems it kind of
makes sense right you said add one
volume get it
but here you'd mix two volumes add
another volume
and it would feel like it was reduced
something in the reaction happened that
gave you a lower volume
what could it possibly be right what was
going on
this is what they were grappling with
this is where they were
and then along comes
avogadro now i
wish we all called him lorenzo romano
amadeo carlo avogadro
which is his full name but we shall call
him avogadro
and he made a critical
proposal he said look
the way to explain what's going on in
guy lu sacks volume measurements
is to make the following
assumption oh i have another board over
here is to make the following assumption
and i think if you've had high school
chemistry you know what this
is but i'm going to put it here because
of how important it
is so avogadro said that
at constant
temperature and pressure
equal volume
equals same
number of particles
so if i have the f i'm at the same
temperature pressure if i have the same
volume
i have the same number of particles now
what are those particles oh he was
flexible
this is important he was flexible he
said those particles could be atoms or
they could be
combinations of atoms it could be
molecules remember at the time they
weren't even
they hadn't all settled on the atom as a
name even
what were these things equal volumes
same number of particles and this
really helped because you see if you
make that assumption
and and you believe these volume
measurements
then it becomes very clear what you have
there
right i can't have if i have the same
number of particles in here
and i believe in lavoisier who tells me
nothing comes in or out in terms of the
mass
i didn't create or destroy atoms then
you know that if i have two volumes of
water
if i start with let's say i started with
o
and h it doesn't work
i can't make enough water
i just can't make enough particles the
the number of particles
on the right has to be equal to the
number of particles
in those two volumes of of hydrogen it's
got to add up
counting has to work that's what
avogadro gave us
is this idea of counting and that's why
we
we've named a constant after him which
i'll get to because
or in honor of avogadro salute
he was italian
and so if you believe avogadro if you
believe avogadro
this becomes clear because
the only way for these things to work
then is if here
you know i'm counting how much volumes
here
so here i'm i've got hcl only if this is
a two
and that's a two diatomic gases
that's the only way the numbers work and
here i've got to have two
and two and this must be h2o oh
or at least it's one simple and very
plausible explanation if avogadro's
hypothesis
was right dalton didn't buy it
dalton said uh uh no way you've got
leaks dude
and and he he really was harsh
right he's uh water is oh everybody
thought water was o-h
at the time right and so dalton said you
must have made a mistake
i block you on instagram
i block you and it was pretty tough
because avocado
you know put a lot of really brilliant
work out there that was
really ignored for 50 years until
canizado came along
and others 50 years later two years
after he died was when
we had the first evidence that the
scientific community was willing to
believe
that his hypothesis was right what a big
deal
his work was now
um okay now i i mentioned that this is
i'm mentioning all this because we are
going to use his constant
a lot the avogadro constant
and it's a way and so i want to talk
about that constant and i want to do it
in the context
of our candle and so because this
constant this number of this idea
of the number of particles you have in
chemistry
is is is the link between the atomic
world
and the macroscopic world that's what
his constant does
for us okay now let's put that into
context
if i were to ask you a question like
this
i have that candle remember the candle
the c25h52
and i say well okay you've lit the
candle how many candle molecules burn in
a minute i want to know that
don't we all right like that's a pretty
important question
i see a lot of people nodding thank you
for that agreement
and i could say well i assume at 12 hour
candle the mass of 90 grams just get
that off of a candle on amazon
right how many molecules burn in a
minute what i need to know is well
how many are we sort of talking about
how do we know how to even answer this
question
and it comes from the link but see to
answer this kind of question
which i'm sure so many people wanted to
know back then you must have
a way to talk about big numbers you must
why because there's a lot of these
molecules
in a very tiny amount of volume a lot
drop of water for perspective has 10
trillion molecules
10 trillion molecules anybody know how
many cells
you have in your body
it's about 100 let's call it 100
trillion just to be nice
right it's 100 trillion cells
and and so we need we you know if you're
going to talk about how many cells you
have or how many
molecules there are in a drop of water
you need to have
a big number a big scale and that
is what a mole is and we name it
avogadro didn't come up with this number
this was gotten much later
right but we name it after him in honor
of the work he did on counting
on counting atoms and molecules and
that's the number
this is the way we talk about it and
just to be
complete avogadro's constant which is
a mole one mole
is equal to 6.022 times
10 to the 23rd it's just a number
right it's just a number but it's a
really important one because it provides
the link so if i asked you how many you
know
okay if i take like how many uh eggs are
there in a dozen eggs
it's 12. how many eggs are how many bags
of sugar are there in a dozen bags of
sugar
is 12 right how many
atoms are there in a mole of atoms that
number
that's all it is it's a number okay
uh oh but a dozen eggs
weighs differently than a dozen bags of
sugar
so a mole of one atom will have a
different amount of mass
a different weight than a mole of
another atom
and that's the link that he gave us
that's the link that this number
gave us and you know in particular again
going back to this idea of counting
we can count now with this link
if i asked you to if i said well how
many pennies are there
and i gave you a mass of pennies right
if i had 2.5
kilograms of pennies and i say how many
pennies do i have
then all i need to know is how much each
penny weighs i'm not going to count them
right you don't want to count them you
want to do something a little
easier so if i have one penny
weighs 2.5 grams
then i know that i can just get this
really easily
i have a thousand pennies
okay what a mole does
a mole gives us the length so a mole
if i have moles then
i can go to the mass of an atom
the mass of an atom
and from that i can go all the way up to
grams
and this is this is critical okay the
mass of the atom
and the grams per mole are the same
number
that's what the mole gives us
right so one mole so so in the in the
case
of carbon
carbon has a mass per atom of 12.011
amu these are atomic
mass units
it's just a way to measure things that
have very little mass
but the link here is that if i have a
mole of these things
if i have a mole one mole
of carbon then i have exactly
12.011 grams
back and forth grams atoms
numbers of atoms mass per atom
all right so one carbon atom has a mass
of 12
atomic mass units we don't need to know
we this is
this comes from weighing neutrons and
protons
we'll get to that next week we don't
need to know that yet
but this isn't a this is a mass of
things at the very tiny scale
and if i have a mole of those atoms i
get to grams
okay so it's my link now
where is this amount where is this
this critical number that gives me the
counting
per gram it's of course here
in your periodic table this is where you
get that information
okay so we'll be building that up as we
go
let's say why does this why why do i
need to count well let's go back to
answer our question now
that's the that's the link that number
avogadro's constant links these atomic
masses to grams
right um
now i can answer the question how many
candle molecules burn
in one minute well let's do that because
now i know that one mole
of c 25 h
52 is something like 352
oh fine 0.7 grams
how do i know that because i can look up
what a mole ways of carbon in here right
how many grams and i can look up how
many grams a mole of hydrogen weighs
and then i can multiply 25 and 52 and
that's how many grams i get
one mole of it is that oh the link is
coming
the link is coming it's very exciting
because in a 12 hour candle
if it's 90 grams so if i have a 90
gram candle as i've said in the problem
then i i know now that that is about
0.25 moles
right because you know because of this
see that 90 over that
so now i know how many moles of candle
i've got
right i know how many moles of candle
i've got but but remember a mole
a a mole is just a number it's just a
number
so this is how many moles of candle
molecules i have
and oh okay i'm gonna in one minute it
says in one minute so in one
minute well okay there's 60 minutes in
an hour and it's 12 hours just a 720
minute candle
right so in one minute 1 720th of that
is what burns if it lasts 12 hours
i'm just taking the information i was
given right and i'm using the math
of minutes and hours 1 720th
okay all right good so hundred 1
twentieth
of the candle burns in one minute one
seven hundred twenty
of the candle burns
and that if the candle is that many
moles that's this many moles
zero point zero zero
nope zero three four
seven moles why did i do all that
because i can now answer the question
because
of avogadro's constant because a mole is
just a number
a mole is just a number so if i've got
that many moles
then i know that i've got 2
times 10 to the 20th
molecules
roughly so i have been able to answer
this question by going back and forth
did you notice
i looked here to get the grams per mole
i figured out how much candle i had
that gave me in grams that gave me how
many moles i have of candle and then
that gave
me the number back and forth back and
forth that's what we do
avogadro's constant gets us in and out
of the atomic world
okay and so we're going to practice that
a little bit
now but and this gets me back to
what we started on wednesday i mentioned
that and i always like to give you guys
advice
if i can and last time i mentioned if
you're on a date at a restaurant
ask them to give you not a candle but
some c25h52
as a test for the quality of the
restaurant now i'm asking you to do
something else
go into yeah it's noisy you want to talk
right you know i don't know first date
is a little nervous
you want to quiet a room ask them for a
if there's a room
where you can kind of shut the door and
get that noise out and it's quiet so you
can talk
but now you are armed with very
important knowledge because
now you know how much volume you have of
air in the room and therefore
how much oxygen you have
and if you light a candle and you're
taking 10 to the 2 times 10 to the 20th
molecules of candle out of the air
by the way how many molecules of oxygen
are you burning
ah how many molecules of oxygen
38 balance 38 times
as many molecules for each one of these
that burns you need 38 molecules of
oxygen
so 38 times
as many o2
now i don't know about you but if i'm on
this date i'm looking it up
humans need the human
needs 1.9 grams
of oxygen per minute
you need that i mean you know maybe it's
variable but you need roughly that and
there's two of you
0.42 grams
of o2 is burned
is burned per
minute
zero point who's gonna win you or the
candle
so you gotta be just aware of this and
now look
i'm not saying that um i'm not saying
this is the kind of thing
we can do now and i'm not saying that
everyone's going to understand this
you might be out you might not be with
an mit student
you might be with a student from some
other school down the street
and i you know all i want to say
be nice be nice it may not be their
fault that they're where they are
it may not be their fault go through
this with them carefully
slowly explain these concepts
and this gets me to the other topic of
conversation that you can have
and this gets me to my why this matters
moment for today
why does this matter why does counting
and thinking about how much
of stuff you're using by using chemistry
and moles why does that matter well
let's take an example
let's take an example of nothing less
than the
the number of humans on this planet
this is the population of humans and you
can see that it wasn't all that much
until lately and but let's focus in on
this part here
let's focus in on that part there right
so that's billions of people
so if i if i zoom in on this there's an
up there's a change look at that it's
kind of
going a little bit up but now it really
kicks up
what happened during that time what
happened
is a very important chemical reaction
became easy to do or a lot easier
okay and the process that enabled that
is called the haber bosch process
but it is what allowed us to feed
billions of people in a sustainable way
well it's arguable whether we're doing
that sustainably but in a way where we
could actually produce enough
enough what enough ammonia and here's
the deal
you see because plants yeah there's
plants need nitrogen to grow
right they but and they're 78 of the
atmosphere is nitrogen
but it's useless because it's n2 and
then 2 is one of the strongest bonds in
nature
and plants can't break it now we knew
how to break it
before we knew how to do this before
right
this is called fixing fixing
nitrogen and the way it works is you go
n2 plus h this is a reaction
goes to nh3 what is wrong with this
it's not balanced thank you
did anybody see balancing is the same as
mole
ratio balancing and mole ratio it's the
same
counting balancing remember we talked
about but balancing is counting
so let's see how oh two here okay that
helps me with the nitrogen
and then i got what do i oh but this is
h2 i meant to put that in the first
place
and then so this is a three that
reaction was known
and doable but it took tremendous
amounts of energy
so it's very difficult to scale and
haberbash came up with a way using
catalysis
to do it at much lower temperatures
catalysis is something we'll learn later
in the semester right
um but how do you answer this question
here's my what's my question
my question is how long can we keep
going
50 of every protein you put in your body
50 percent comes from this comes from
some plant that was grown using this
process that's how important it is
it's 500 million tons
of nitrogen is made this way every year
well it's just counting one mole
of ammonia is 17 grams oh we're doing
the same thing
how did i know that periodic table
that's how i knew that
one mole if i have that many molecules
of ammonia i've got 17 grams of it
and but i need
let's say i just need to make the same
amount of
says so times 10 to the six tons
i need that much tons of
nh3 per year that's sorry yeah per year
per year okay so that sets up my problem
i know how much i need i know how much
you know how many atoms we're talking
about in one mole
now i can actually understand how many
moles so i'm just going to
not do the detailed math but how many
moles i have so i've got
30 times 10 to the 12th
moles this is how many moles i need
of needed okay per year
how much do i have well we know how much
the atmosphere weighs it turns out
we know how much the atmosphere weighs
the mass of the atmosphere
the mass of the atmosphere
is something like 5 times 10
to the 21st grams and
if i take 78
of that as my n2 right
so 78
is n2 then i can
tell you that i've got uh let's see 1.4
times 10 to the 20th moles
of n2 that's how much i have available
okay so if i keep on taking into out of
the atmosphere
then i can now answer the question just
like the candle right how long do you
have
i can answer the question how long can
we keep taking energy
n2 out of the atmosphere and using haber
bosch
right oh well you would use the balance
reaction so for every mole of n2 i take
i get two moles of ammonia
that's good and you can work backwards
and you can learn that you're good
we're good for now for now we have
something like
we have roughly 100 million years
okay we have 100 million years that we
could consume
um we have 100 million years that we
could keep consuming
uh and then we'll run out of n2 in the
atmosphere that's
how fun was that okay i love
doing these now when i get excited
wow wait before i get excited what's the
limiting reagent
is it n2 how do you know
how could you show how could you prove
limiting reagent means what runs out
first well oh i'll just take h2 from the
atmosphere right
uh there's no h2 in the atmosphere
where's the h2 it's over here
h2o it's in the oceans how much h2o do i
have
oh
it turns out you got a lot 10 to the
23rd
ish moles of h2o right 10 to the 23ish
moles
and so because of those coefficients of
the reaction
you know exactly which one is going to
run out first you know it's n2 so your
answer over there
was correct and two is the limiting i
love that little dance i'm gonna try to
learn that i'm going to learn that later
if if if you try this you go 100 million
years you run out of into plenty of h2
left
limiting region when i get excited i
also i didn't mention this
i like to throw stuff like t-shirts now
the thing is
these t-shirts are not
now and i go like this
and then i go all the way
to the back all the way up there
and all the way up there
all right okay now look
why do i throw t-shirts i have no idea
sometimes things just are better left
unknown
but please i'll throw t-shirts
i'll throw t-shirts 34 more times every
lecture i'm going to throw some t-shirts
when i get a little excited
and please if you get a t-shirt a second
time share
right don't don't take you give it to
somebody trade
right sharing is carry now where were we
okay
now here we are we got we got to build
this
here's the thing
in 1669 there were only 12 elements
known but yeah i hope i've given you a
sense all these people and many more i
haven't even named
we're working on discovering new ones
by 1799
we had 34. dalton i mentioned had a
table of 36 and they kept going
and as we got more and more elements
a lot of people are running how do we
organize these
how do we organize these and are there
patterns
are there patterns right that became
a hot question yes they still wanted to
smash and break and burn and make new
discover new things but they also wanted
to know what it all means
it wasn't just like a few it was a lot
and so they started looking for patterns
and one of the first
uh people was dove reiner who who who
came up with what he called the law of
triads
which was a law that worked three times
but but what he found everybody was like
arranging these elements
in different ways range it by mass
no range it by something else and he
found that
you know if you listed him kind of by
mass ish then the middle atom
of the three would weigh exactly half or
roughly half
of these two that was cool for three
times
okay uh newlands newlands did something
really important well first of all he
he loved music he
arranged elements like this and again
kind of by mass and he noticed
that there were repeating patterns every
eight
now unlike the law of triads this was
really important because the law of
triads just said look i can i can take
these three i can
take those three that's kind of cool but
it wasn't periodic
it didn't happen these three then the
next three and
whereas new orleans it was periodic
it sort of also only worked for two and
a half runs
the law of octaves he called it the law
of octaves
oh this was the time to look for
patterns and many people took a stab at
it
um meyer julius meyer made some really
important
contributions in in measuring the molar
volume by knowing the densities
and finding patterns patterns they were
looking
for periodicity but as many of you may
already know
it was mendeleev
who figured out what needed to be done
and and what he figured out was
absolutely critical
let's go to the middle
he came up and oh notice he's listing
them oh okay he didn't know whether to
put it this way or sideways or what
right so this is actually
different this is oriented differently
than what we do today but it's okay
he's just listing them and looking for
patterns but what mendeleev did that was
so critical what he did
that was so important is that he looked
for these he he organized them so
mendeleev
mendeleev he had
at the time this was let's see 1869
he had 63 elements
and he called this a periodic system
and the critical piece is he arranged
them
by mass
and this is so important properties
he really believed that
the periodicity was the driver the
driver
and that the properties were critical in
this
organization the properties and the mass
right but he was you know
he he was so certain that that you had
to take them both into account
that that he actually left
gaps that was new
at least for for this many elements
arranging it this way
that was different and so like for
example look at this over here
what you know so here you have aluminum
silicon
all right and you gotta uncover this so
you can see it oh
zinc okay zinc right arsenic but he said
no don't just put this next to zinc
because of the properties
this doesn't have the right properties
this should be more like phosphorus
so we're going to leave gaps and he even
called he predicted and this
is really important he predicted the
properties of those missing elements
so you could call those for example with
silicon
we know this is germanium we know that
now but but back then no one had smashed
and burned and broken enough stuff
to find germanium so he said well we can
predict it
because it comes here in this table in
this organization
therefore it must have properties
similar
to other elements in that column and he
called it ika silicon eco just means one
next right
and so these are predictions by
mendeleev predictions of the properties
of this missing element
and here's what you get when you
actually find germanium
years and years later and you measure
those properties and look at that
it's incredible right thank you for that
wow
because i felt it too is there any more
t-shirts
ah i felt the wow and it made me excited
all right this is a big deal you go back
to here
iodine and tellurium no i'm not going to
give you the mass ordering
because it doesn't make sense in terms
of property so i'm going to keep the
mass the other way the
even though this has a higher mass look
at that question mark
i'm still going to put it before because
it makes more sense
that's what mendeleev did and it was
absolutely critical
and it brought it really brings us to
the current system that we use
so this is now the periodic table our
periodic table today is based on
mendeleev's organization and
i'm not we're going to be spending a lot
of time with it right so we're not going
to go through everything but a couple of
things
first of all there's a key that's the
key to the table
if a table doesn't have the key don't
use it
it should have a key and and so for
example
oh look at that number that looks nice
right that's the amu or the grams per
mole which we now know are equivalent
not equivalent but relatable right if
you have a mole
that's how many grams you have or if you
have one atom that's how many amuse you
have
right there the key tells you what
things are
right now
if you have a more complicated one don't
panic here's yours
this is your periodic table
look at this it's all in the key
there's a lot more information in here
than in the basic ones
but it's all in the key it's all
described in the key and the key may be
different on the front
and the back there may be different
properties included
right but it's all in the key and look
at this some of these we know like the
weight
atomic weight that's what we've been
talking about melting point sounds kind
of obvious boiling point density
and then you get to these other things
electronegativity first ionization
all these things what are they we will
find out
literally next week right
as we build up our understanding of the
atom
but it's on the key now this is so
important that i
i really ask you with passion
to carry it with you everywhere you go
i really do because you never know
remember the restaurant example
you never know when you need it you
never know
and and in fact you can send me pictures
students do this i love it i don't you
don't have to send me pictures
you can just post it on your feed or
whatever it's called
feed what's it called i don't know a
thing and
but and i like look at how so you they
took it all the way up to dartmouth
because there were some people up there
apparently that needed
help with their chemistry here we are
at a restaurant looking at at the
periodic table here's another
it's a good it's a good thing to have at
a restaurant you never know
um here it is again look at look at how
happy they are
look at that right uh they're they're
they're really getting into it they're
really getting into it here
uh teaching teaching teaching family
members
right about this or being proud of it
with the whole family
take it with you it'll come in handy no
matter what
here it is under a christmas tree right
um it's in here somewhere um and and
there it is
and look even if you're dressing up uh
for a theater
it's gonna be important um okay now this
is the one i want to get to
okay even if you're a little tired it's
gonna be what comforts you
i think it's being used as a pillow
that's okay
it's comfortable and this is look at
this
right right you know
even at the dance club even at the dance
club oh i see that
you might need this you don't know you
don't know
look at how happy he is look at that
because he has this take it
with you everywhere you go
now there's a bunch of things about this
table that we'll be talking about
right we just built it up um
one of the the first things is just some
nomenclature right just
how do we name things we name things the
the
the rows we call them periods and
there's seven of them
the columns we call them groups and
there's 18 of them
in the way we organize in the way we
present it right
um but there's something kind of
important that happens here which is
that
these rows down here are actually 14
elements longer
they would actually go so right so this
is 18 across
but these guys fit in right here they go
right there
right these are called the lanthanides
because that's lanthanum
right innovative naming these are called
the actinides
right okay they go in there in between
why don't we just put it all there well
you can but then you got the bottom rows
are 34
right and then the next one's up there's
only two rows in the periodic table that
are actually 18
right then because then you got 18 here
all right and then these
are eight and then you got two up top
now why
that we will understand when we
understand the atom a little better next
week
okay but for now i just want to call
your attention that these are the names
that we use
and those top ones are called main group
these ones are transition elements
um you have alkalis here you have
lanthanides
actinides these are the names that we
give these regions that get more clear
when we know
what electrons are and i think um
i'll i'll i'll tell you just the last
bits about
uh you know just a couple more
observations about the periodic table
i think um when we start our lecture on
monday since it's 11 54
and as promised i want to let you guys
out right on time every lecture
have a fantastic weekend and see you
monday
you